all right the national lacrosse leagues
has expanded into Las Vegas you know
something about this 2022 marks the
arrival of the Vegas desert dogs and
earlier I caught up with one of their
star players
the Las Vegas desert dogs have arrived
and I've got I'm calling them already
one of their star players Eric Turner is
here with us buddy how excited are you
about this new season we're ecstatic uh
it was kind of a little bit of a tease
in the first week we had a buy which was
great because we're a new team and gave
us a little bit more time to prepare but
waiting to get into that first game was
really hard so last week it was great to
get on the floor finally and we've
really been excited about our first home
game and our new community and and it's
it's a lot of excitement around here
well Las Vegas is excited to have you
here and you've been playing in the
league for how many years this is my
third season and there's a new draft you
got plucked and brought here from where
uh from Colorado and Colorado last year
were the champions
when it comes to display Congratulations
by the way winning the championship last
year when it comes to playing lacrosse I
mean what should we be looking for when
we're watching the game I think the
thing that stands out the most is the
speed and physicality that that really
stands out to people right away there's
a ton of contact things move fast we
have a shot clock there's like a
combination of a basketball and hockey
kind of rule set and then there is this
High physicality level where guys are
getting hit all the time lots of huge
impacts and then this like skill level
with this tiny rubber ball that's flying
around at high speeds and this thing is
hard too it's hard it's not this is not
it's a very this is a hard ball here how
fast is this going our offensive guys
will shoot around like 90 miles per hour
pretty consistently when they're on the
outside and just the the accuracy of the
placement there's about like 22 goals
per game score between the two teams so
lots of scoring it's fast it's fast and
lots of scoring lots of physicality
really entertaining to watch Eric before
we go connect the pro make a shot right
now let's get it come on oh and now the
rookie
we'll have more with Eric coming up